our house collapsed my only grandmother
died from the injuries she suffered so i
turned my painful
past into a motivation i never knew that
what i'm doing will turn this big
to me and to the environment
i felt unloved i felt discriminated
because of my often falling sick from
malaria
i am now part of the solution in my
country
two people each with a vision joe
nalabego produces soap with a scent that
repels mosquitoes
according to the un every two minutes a
child under the age of five
dies of malaria
even if i'm not saving all the kids that
are suffering right now
i am at least saving the ones that i can
john mary kavuma is founder and director
of the green business upcycle africa
which builds houses out of recycled
plastic bottles
we are transforming the western crisis
in africa
into employment opportunities for
manganese groups of people
so we are constructing affordable homes
kavuma and nalubega are graduates of the
social innovation academy
or cena for short it's located in the
town of mpigi
about 30 kilometers south of uganda's
capital kampala
here young people including orphans and
street kids learn how to develop their
ideas into successful businesses
due to the covet 19 pandemic only a few
students are currently able to attend
classes on campus
it is not giving them information like a
teacher this is what you need to do or
this is the right answer
but helping them to discover their own
answers to understand
what are the next steps what are the
goals how can they achieve what they
want to achieve
german social entrepreneur etienne
zaiborn founded cena in 2014
for people who want to build their own
career paths the academy is financed by
donations
it's been over ten years since zeiburn
met joan and john mary while
volunteering in an orphanage
they've known each other a long time
zaibon quickly realized that a lot of
young people in uganda
have no formal work the country has one
of the youngest and fastest growing
populations
in africa especially in uganda
people are not prepared to to work
together to present themselves to ask
critical
questions to find their own solutions
their own answers
and we are learning that in cena and
that's why often
not everybody will become an
entrepreneur but many of our scholars as
well that have been in cena
have found jobs one of the solutions led
to kampala where plastic waste is a huge
problem
350 000 tons of trash accumulate in the
ugandan capital every year
and only half of it is disposed of
much of the plastic lands on this trash
dump
recycling isn't common here john mary
kavuma
pays young trash collectors to gather
bottles that he can then use to build
houses
every time i come here and i do like
give some money to other people to do
for example recycling
or keeping our environment clean it
gives me a lot of hope that even the
future generation
will inherit a healthy planet that we
have we have done or we have protected
from plastic waste
earth is pressed into the plastic
bottles to make bricks
many women work for kavumi's business
giving them the chance to earn their own
money
our wages were raised recently
now i can pay my daughter's university
tuition
and give her the opportunity to graduate
kavuma says the houses are cool inside
even on hot days
his business has already constructed
more than 100 buildings
using over 3 million plastic bottles in
the process
due to the coronavirus pandemic
commissions have slowed
but there is funding coming in from
abroad we are revising our different
solutions
on the way we can be able to survive as
a company however we also got
some people who came around to support
us
for example we got some funding from
ikea and achievement that decided to
support us and
especially in the ella of kobe d19
this woman supplies joan ellabega with
lemongrass a key ingredient in her soap
she brings some bars by these days for
free
before the covet 19 crisis she sold her
soap to tourists and hotels for a higher
price
so she could keep the price down for
locals now that there are hardly any
tourists
she's expanded her online business
it helps that the soap's effectiveness
has been scientifically verified
[Music]
in the past people often got sick with
malaria
especially children but since we've been
using the soap
it's been a while since anyone here has
had malaria
the refugee settlement nakivale in
western uganda
it provides shelter for more than 100
000 people
who fled the violence in neighboring
countries such as south sudan
many people have lived here for years
including victim mafiger
together with etienne zaibon he brought
this senile model to nakivale
finding work tends to be even harder for
refugees than for young ugandans
a few of victor's trainees have already
been awarded prize money at music
festivals
[Music]
in nakivala refugee settlement there are
a lot of young people with
dormant skills people who
don't have no more chances to go to
school
and also no opportunities we come to
realize that refugees artists can not
only depend on ads
but they can also doing something else
to earn a living
but there have also been setbacks
because of cobit 19 a cena branch in
south africa had to be put on hold
nevertheless etienne zalbon remains
convinced that cena will play a part in
more success stories
like those of john mary kavuma and joan
nalabega
i have a vision to make my country a
better place i have a vision to
make africa instead of running away from
it
to make it a better place if my
grandmother happened to see me now i
know she'll be proud of me
you